As, you know,
one of the pick me that won the game of life,
I scored a man, I got the wedding,
I got the ring, I got the dress,
I got the kids, I got all of it.
I Learned to be careful what you fucking wish for.
And I want other white
passing Latina women who snatch up the white boys to understand
you're only useful because you're a tool to them.
They are getting to say, I wrangled a wild one,
do you know what I'm saying?
But you're still just a tool,
a whole. For whatever game they wanna play at the time.
Because I understand
it's like my job to stand in front of the people with like
less power than me
and kinda shield them and kinda stop the fucking line.
It's like my job. I gotta stop it here,
you know? Like,
they come for the black women,
they're gonna come for the brown ones next,
and then they'll come for the yellow ones after that,
and then whatever fucking other thing they will use to divide us.
And like, that's always fucking made sense to me.
Like, you're not valued just because I just. Women,
I just like super wish women.
Women wouldn't play into the fucking game
because it's just to separate us. It's just hurt us.
Be careful what you fucking wish for.